>> This is Cheryl Lederle from the Library
of Congress and I welcome you to this,
our second annual online
conference for teachers.
And it is my pleasure to welcome Sherry Levitt.
Sherry is the Executive Director of Teaching
with Primary Sources, northern Virginia,
delivering professional development
to K16 educators throughout
the commonwealth of Virginia.
Prior to her current work, Miss Levitt was the
high school English Language Arts Curriculum
Specialist for Fairfax County Public Schools.
She holds an advanced degree in English
with 25 years of classroom experience
as a teacher and department chair.
And Sherry, we are delighted
to welcome you, this afternoon,
to share your knowledge and experiences.
>> Hello, everyone.
I'm just so glad to be with you, today.
I hope everybody's comfortable, settled in,
and that we'll have some useful
and enjoyable time together.
From my many years as an English and Humanities
teacher, I know and I think you'd agree,
that students love a great story,
particularly if it really happened.
I think the true stories embedded
in primary sources offer irresistible
invitations to students to find out more.
And along the way learn good habits
of scholarship and attribution.
And really, that's at the heart
of my presentation, tonight.
I'm going to model an approach to student
inquiry and research that captures the theme
of this year's conference, ''Discovering
and Exploring Primary Sources
from the Library of Congress''.
And I hope we'll look at some intriguing
stories from one year in our nation's history.
So, the primary source images you'll
be seeing, are all hyperlinked.
So, you can find your way
back to anything to interest.
And the images come primarily from the prints
and photographs collection, historic newspapers,
and their very excellent teacher's page,
that has easy access educational
resources for all of us.
And throughout this presentation, please,
I welcome your reflections and ideas
and maybe you've tried something similar.
Suggest adaptations.
I'd love to hear from you.
From a student's perspective, I think
history can be so confusing and it's
like a puzzle, maybe, with a thousand pieces.
And I think confining an investigation
to some of the events from just one year
in our history can act as a
sorting mechanism, and then,
as a mirror reflecting forward to our own times.
So, here's the challenge [inaudible].
I like project based learning very much,
and I have incorporated some
of the ideas in this model.
And I've issued, here, a challenge to students
to investigate the events
of one year in history.
And then, match with primary sources
and make connections to our own times.
And please note the date
on the photograph, there.
And perhaps, you're in that same comfortable
lounging position, as we're working here.
So, the role of the teacher
in this project idea,
is to decide the course standards
and learning goals.
And really, to develop the plans in advance,
so that once the challenge has been issued the
teacher acts more in the role of a facilitator.
But really, there's a lot of deliberate
design in structures, routines,
and guidelines that push students
toward completion of the project,
encapsulating course standards,
skills, and learning goals.
So, a very deliberate building of
this before it even gets under way.
A good approach, is to provide rule
[inaudible] and graphic organizers
for the important steps and
always with flexibility.
Because adjustments will
inevitably, requires some flexibility.
And of course, a teacher ensures balance by
requiring focus on a variety of categories,
but across a broad spectrum
of categories, please.
So, there's cultural, social, political,
economic, scientific, environmental, categories,
so that the project doesn't just
become one year [inaudible].
And of course, analyzing primary sources.
And we'll talk about a good
way to do that in just a bit.
And to go deeper than just having the
primary sources simply illustrate the event.
And throughout, the teacher
works with students conferring,
supporting, differentiating as needed.
And assessing at every step,
keeping students on track.
These assessments could be
daily logs, journal entries,
peer evaluation, exit tickets, focus groups.
You probably have some more ideas.
And certainly, a detailed bibliography would
be an important part of a summative assessment.
And I'd also like to recommend
some flexibility in date range.
And I've done that, here.
I've taken a few liberties.
Sometimes, a bibliographic record of
a primary source isn't all that clear.
And every single item at the Library of
Congress does come with a bib record.
But sometimes a specific
date is a little nuanced.
And the role of the student.
The student chooses a year, far enough
removed in time so that they would be likely
to have sufficient primary sources,
even from the world's largest
library, to avoid frustration.
And also, time to investigate several
choices before a final decision.
So, it goes without saying, that each
group should have a different year.
And the teacher should ensure that students can
identify a primary versus a secondary source.
And also, the various formats in
which primary sources can come.
And to think about the skills
they are developing as they work
through the steps toward the final product,
of collaboration, critical thinking,
problem solving, and building
content knowledge, as well.
So, in project based learning an audience, which
ideally includes people outside the classroom,
is a wonderful idea, maybe
parents, teachers, specialists,
and the final project options
can take many forms.
Magazines with articles, poems, political
cartoons, performances, website design, video.
And during their presentation, their public
presentations, student groups should be prepared
to share and discuss their choices.
To process and field questions
from the audience with attention
to good oral communications skills.
So, you might have guessed, I have
chosen 1920 to model how this might look.
I've always been interested about the concept
of decades, as if somebody flips a switch,
and suddenly, it's the Gilded Age, the
Roaring Twenties, or the Great Depression.
I mean, every year has significant events.
Some more than others.
And the question for students,
again, is why is the year,
whatever they choose, important in our history?
And how does it connect to our own times?
So, listed on the slide are some of the
people, events, and places I encountered
as I consulted secondary source material.
And perhaps, you are familiar with the
term Zeitgeist, or the defining spirit
or mood of a particular period, excuse
me, period of history that's reflected
in the ideas and beliefs of the time.
And that's another aspect of this project,
to capture some of that zeitgeist we need
to develop empathy for the
real people living back then.
So, from the students' point of
view, where would I look to begin?
Probably timelines would be a good idea.
And if you were a student, how would
you start the process of finding
out about the events of one year?
Well, for timelines, a caveat.
Because like so much else
students encounter on the internet,
timelines may be selective,
and not entirely free of bias.
So, students need to source and to verify.
For example, I kept coming up with this claim.
And I'll give you a moment to look at that.
And I couldn't believe that
possibly could be true.
And yet, when I went to verify it,
I'll give you a moment to read this.
I found this 2013 blog from
the Smithsonian Institution.
So, the teacher can help the process along
by recommending some reliable timelines
and requiring citation of
the ones that students use.
So, once they've decided on the
particular events to investigate,
they can begin using the Library of
Congress website to collect primary sources
and making contemporary connections.
But after locating a primary
source that looks promising,
how do they begin to really
analyze it carefully?
The Library of Congress, for many years, has had
this valuable approach, a three-step approach
to analyzing primary sources, which is online,
with versions customized
in a variety of formats.
And this is the basic one, with steps
to observe and reflect and question.
The circle in the upper right-hand
corner illustrates
that it's not a linear process,
but really a recursive one.
So, this primary source analysis tool can help
students generate new questions for research.
Let's see how this works.
Let's try it ourselves, with a 1920 image
that I found in Prints and Photographs.
So, please take a moment now.
I'm going to hold you to this.
For some time, I read somewhere recently, from
James Elkins, who's an art critic and historian
from the Art Institute of Chicago, that
people in a museum who visit a museum,
found maybe spent an average of
ten seconds, sometimes up to 17,
looking at an image before moving on.
And that the Louvre found that people looked at
the Mona Lisa for an average of only 15 seconds.
So, let's conduct our primary source analysis.
Put yourself in the role of the student
and please begin listing everything
you see in this photograph.
Let me hold you here for a full minute,
and see what you can come up with.
Just what you observe.
Okay. I'm calling time.
And now, please move on to your reflections.
Maybe the background knowledge you already have.
And questions.
You might want to find out more.
And what do you hypothesize?
What's going on, here?
What would you like to find out?
Well, fortunately, the Library of Congress
has information for us in the bib record.
And I like that.
Men. Seem to be some type of team.
You're absolutely right, Mary.
And they're learning the dance, but why?
New perspective on sport training.
Excellent.
And that really is very close.
The title of this photograph is ''The
Charleston as an Aid to the Game''.
Vivian Marinelli is giving
dance lessons to the members
of the Palace Club basketball
team of Washington, DC.
The subject of jazz and dance crazes
appeared on several 1920 timelines.
So, I consulted an historic newspaper
collection ''Chronicling America''.
Here it is.
This is a great resource for teachers.
It's a database of historic newspapers
published between 1836 and 1922.
I used the search engine and the
date range for 1920 to find articles
about dancing, and came up with this one.
Spend a moment to read the
headline from the Chattanooga News,
and please record your reaction to this, and
any contemporary connections you can make.
The name of the database is Chronicling America.
And Cheryl noted there's a
session on that, tomorrow.
And really, I see my colleague Cynthia, is
who I passed beyond the chat and she and I,
we love this resource when
we work with teachers.
A literation overkill.
Absolutely.
So, this led me to recommended topics.
This is a feature in Chronicling America that's
especially valuable for student research.
It lists subjects widely covered in
the American press in that date range.
And it's searchable by alphabetical
listing, subject category, and date range.
It makes for fascinating browsing.
It's almost a little dangerous, when
you're supposed to be doing other things.
But here is where I found the connection
between the dance crazes of 1920 and jazz music.
And you can read the little
descriptor at the top.
There are the selected best pages on the
topic, as well as background information.
And dancing was I learned, and jazz music
often described as moral, ugly, and ridiculous.
And I even found an article from the New
York Tribune that read, ''Jazz is responsible
for most of the evils, say teachers.'' And
an aside about these historic newspapers,
advertisements talk about the zeitgeist,
wonderful windows into the past
and a feeling for the time period.
Take a look at these.
Especially that one in the middle.
Three examples form 1920,
from the Washington Times
and maybe imagine how your students would react.
And what connections we could make
to our own advertising and media.
The generation gap never does change.
Every timeline and text I consulted about 1920,
the 18th Amendment figured
prominently in major events.
And as you probably know, the 18th Amendment
prohibited sale and transport of alcohol.
But I learned that the ideas about controlling
alcohol began more than a century before.
And that's an interesting story and
a research project for another time.
And you probably also, recall that the
18th Amendment caused widespread disregard
for the law and a surge in organized
crime, before it was repealed in 1933.
And here, we have a photograph,
admittedly opposed photograph,
but it's still a primary source.
And it's a deputy police
commissioner, John A. Leach,
watching agent pouring liquor
into a sewer, following a raid.
And I wonder what connections
you can make to our own times?
Such a waste.
So, here's another interesting photograph
I found, this time, in Chronicling America,
that might spur students to
grapple with some text features.
And practice their literacy skills.
What words grab your attention to look at this?
What do we need to find out?
And how are we going to go about it?
Bootlegs. Absolutely.
Bootlegs. All you have to do
is look at a good dictionary.
And most agree that a pair of bootlegs refers
to smuggled liquor that's hidden in boots.
A czar, you know we think of
czar, an environmental czar,
a legislative czar, as a modern term.
But here it is, 1920, and the
office of the Prohibition Czar.
And we have Miss Hattie Klawans
and then, the caption there.
So, I have a bonus crime question
for you, if you recognize.
I couldn't resist including this man, because
I was shocked that it went so far back.
I'm sure you've heard of Ponzi schemes, rather.
This is a mug shot of Carlo Ponzi, who was
up to shenanigans back at this time period.
I don't think you'd recognize him.
And moving on to political cartoons.
Take a look at this one.
it really provides a bridge between
the 18th and the 19th Amendments.
The 19th Amendment was ratified on August
18th, 1920, granting American women the right
to vote, known as Women's Suffrage.
And the Library of Congress has extensive
resources on the subject, including this cartoon
from a primary source set on the teacher page.
Can you see what's written on the bottle?
The bottle's label says,
''Injustice, intolerance, hypocrisy,
and that scary genie is tearing
at the woman's banner.
And the banner reads, ''Votes for women''.
What's the connection?
I think this would be something older
students might puzzle out and interpret.
And that is the question.
How are these two issues conflated?
You know, some research might reveal
that the groups that supported and pushed
through the 18th Amendment might be dangerous
allies, because of the 18th Amendment,
subsequent problems, and
unintended consequences.
I'm going to move ahead to
make sure we cover more
of the primary sources we
have on Women's Suffrage.
Here's sheet music and a poster image from
the primary source set on the teacher's page.
It's got sound files, photographs,
letters, and maps.
And really, it's just a wonderful
aid in helping understand a subject.
And there's also a free eBook
version of student discoveries.
And through all of these, you know,
the opportunity to examine persuasion
and propaganda techniques in support of a cause
and how this works today,
how differently, today.
Wonderful images around the changing
roles and perceptions of women in 1920.
Take a look at the three of
these differing perspectives
and the connections we could make today.
Yes, that's, ''My Little Bimbo''.
That's a sheet music cover.
The elegant woman at the bottom
poster is smoking a cigarette.
And the title of this one is, ''Where
There's Smoke, There's Fire''.
And in the middle, a photograph
of a Flapper Girl,
probably an invented image,
for a Flapper, more authentic.
And where do you think students would think
the name flapper might have come from?
Well, the term ''flapper''
apparently, from what I can tell
in my research, originated in Great Britain.
Where there was a short fad among young women
to wear rubber galoshes and leave them open
so that they'd flap as they walked.
And the name stuck.
And flapper became synonymous with a liberated
young woman, scandalous galoshes, indeed.
And again, the true line to our times, I think
kids would immediately get the connection
with what is considered interesting, today.
And a screenshot of Chronicling America,
which I hope you'll go investigate
background information and articles.
And I found so much information, here.
Primary source information.
And popular culture, reflected
in the films of 1920.
You know, a few of the timelines I looked at,
marked 1920 as the rise of the movie industry.
And a comparison, I think, of today's popular
culture with that of a past year in history,
would likely engage students, very
much, and spark inquiry and research.
And here are some of the library resources.
Any resonance with beams and
subject matter in contemporary film?
I can tell you that I found lots
of pirates and lots of cowboys.
And that seems to be an enduring popularity.
I love this entry from the teacher blog.
If you have never used it, I highly
recommend it, addressing stereotypes in humor
and historic film clips to view
from the library's collection.
And that movie poster in the middle.
That's a nice accompaniment.
But capturing cultural norms and
societal values, nothing, I think,
is as effective as some of
these primary sources.
And I was fascinated by, ''The Crimson
Skull'', with an all African American cast.
Fascinating lures to research.
I want to find out more,
and imagine you might, too.
And in sports.
Here's Babe Ruth at bat,
Garrett is catching in 1920.
And with the World Series about to get underway,
with historic results, whichever team wins.
Here is a terrific photo of Babe Ruth.
And although the bib record for this
photograph doesn't have much information,
the page will point to related
resources at the library.
So, there's also opportunities.
Here is a primary source set.
As I read about baseball in 1920, I learned that
Babe Ruth hit a homerun out of the Polo Grounds.
I learned that spitballs were
allowed, and that the Negro Leagues,
as they were called, were first recognized.
But for further research, the library's
teacher page has this wonderful set,
''Baseball Across a Divided Society'', your
students are likely to find of great interest.
There's baseball songs, cards, letters,
speeches, as well as information
about some of the baseball greats.
Like Roger Maris, Ty Cobb, and others.
But what I like about this collection,
it goes beyond simply offering
interesting primary sources,
and looks at our national pastime
through the lens of desegregation.
The Jackie Robinson story, for example.
And I would be asking students, are
these issues still with us today?
Are there true lines that
we trace to our own time?
And I want to say, here, I know you all may
do some related projects, something similar.
And I'd love to hear the
versions that you've created.
And let's go back to Chronicling America,
where I found the Black Sox Scandal of 1920.
Here it is.
Think I've got an arrow.
Oop. I don't Okay.
But you can read the headline.
There. The Black Sox Scandal of 1920.
And really, baseball fans, I
think, would immediately point
to some contemporary scandals from our own time.
And that's, when I searched by the date range,
I found there were some other very unpleasant
and ominous undercurrents at
work during the year 1920.
And there, the Ku Klux Klan
adding thousands of members.
This one's from my home state of
Connecticut, Bridgeport, Connecticut.
And I think that headline speaks for itself.
I found this, as well.
My research came across some startling
statistics regarding the growth of the Klan
at its peak, almost five million members
up to, some sources say, eight million.
Including members of Congress,
several mayors, and governors.
And six years after this
photograph was taken in 1920,
the Klan would hold a massive
parade in Washington, DC.
I think that's such an important point, Cynthia.
So, it didn't just happen in a vacuum.
You know, how did it happen?
What were the influences that
led to the rise of the Klan?
And again, the parallels to our own times.
As the develop their project and presentations,
students can learn great habits
of scholarship and attribution.
By avoiding Google images.
Somebody earlier in the chat, pointed
to that would be the, you know,
the natural place that the kids would first go.
But the Library of Congress, here's a
screenshot of a typical bibliographic record
from the library that accompanies the
photograph from the previous slide.
And I know that the print is small.
But I especially appreciate the rights advisory.
So, no known restrictions.
No, it's copyright free.
You can use it.
And then, also, this is a real boon
to research, citation guide in MLA,
APA, and Chicago style, I believe.
And this, I was shocked to discover this.
I had not known or ever heard of this.
But apparently in 1920, in Duluth, Minnesota,
three men were lynched on June 15th.
Three African American circus workers.
And their names are Elias Clayton,
Elmer Jackson, Isaac McGhee.
They were attacked and lynched by a
mob, because of rumors circulating
that they had assaulted and
robbed a teenage girl.
Physician's examination revealed no
evidence that any assault ever took place.
But apparently, no one was
ever punished for the murders.
However, in 2003, the city of Duluth
erected a memorial to the murdered men.
And I imagine your students would be able
to research and furnish modern day examples
of this kind of racial intolerance.
And I love Mary Johnson's
[assumed spelling] recommendation
to always collaborate with librarians.
I certainly agree.
There are other dark undercurrents
during the year 1920.
And this time, this one, connecting
indirectly maybe to world events.
Again, back in recommended topics,
I read about the Palmer Raids.
And this is a paper from Ogden,
Utah, 1920, January third.
There had been bombings and strikes.
And the Attorney General, Alexander Palmer,
set about a campaign to crush suspected reds.
And that's how far back that term goes.
And anarchists.
And thousands were arrested
and hundred deported.
Some connections to our own times, perhaps.
So, a time of high anxiety in America.
And you know, why?
Why was that?
And Cynthia, that's true.
Let me go back.
Cynthia notes the connection to
Russia, right on that same page.
I meant to point that out.
So, the time period, 1920.
These undercurrents from the interwar years.
World War One had just ended two years, before.
And the sense of loss and devastation was
captured in the literature of this year.
Here is some first edition dust jackets.
I'll let you admire those.
And a photograph.
You recognize who that is?
If you said the Fitzgeralds, you would be right.
That's Zelda and F. Scott Fitzgerald.
The expatriate writers, living in Europe and
following World War One, you probably recall,
became a great force in American literature.
And among good books published
in 1920, ''Main Street''.
I don't know if you've read that.
Anybody read that?
Very depressing look at small town
life in America, by Sinclair Lewis.
''This Side of Paradise'' was the
debut novel of F. Scott Fitzgerald.
A real sensation.
And also, his collection of short
fiction, ''Flappers and Philosophers''.
And you recognize who that is typing, up there.
That's Ernest Hemingway.
And in 1920, Fitzgerald introduced Maxwell
Perkins, a famous editor from Scribner's,
who introduced him, to Ernest Hemingway.
So, I would ask, why were they
called the Lost Generation?
What connections would we make to today, if any?
The book on the left, refers to the
signing of the Treaty of Versailles
on June 28th, 1919, ending World War One.
And you can read the title, ''The Greatest
Moment in History'', according to the authors.
Woodrow Wilson proposed a League of Nations,
but debate over the U.S. membership
is captured in the sheet music cover.
It's clever.
I found this very curious jewelry.
It's an anti-League of Nations emblem pin.
And this would be a good one for students.
I mean, how do we let people
know what we are thinking to.
>> And this is Cheryl.
I've muted Sherry.
I'm not sure that she can hear me.
But I am obligated to end this session on time.
Because we do have another session coming.
>> I see the time is quickly
approaching and I'm ten minutes up.
So, I have enjoyed this very much.
And I would love to hear from you.
And there's the contact information
where you can reach me.